i know we're going from topic to topic
fast here but speaking of that kind of
topic of uh
manga and uh anime adaptations and
whatnot not getting it right
yeah i recently watched and read records
of ragnarok
okay okay and i know that's gonna be
because when i was live streaming people
were like
oh well netflix paid you to react to it
so you can't say a bad thing about it no
that's not true we can say bad things
about it
and i'm going to yeah it's so so yeah
with uh
with that as well yeah we just reacted
to it it wasn't yet you have to say good
thing it was like react to it but you
know if you
please please don't be too mean you know
yeah don't like rip us to shreds and
like not gonna be like oh i think you
ring me here netflix wow this looks like
[ __ ] yeah
and when we're talking about it i i will
give my honest opinions on to be fair
the scenes that we did react to were
probably the better scenes
yeah they definitely showed us the
better fight of the two even then it was
like you know it was all right yeah yeah
it was just compared to the manga
because because like i will say this
yeah we you know we obviously were
sponsored by netflix to react to it
and we tried to give like i mean i was
honestly hype
for the show in general because i'm a
huge fan of the manga so i was pretty
hype and
we were obviously shown we weren't
showed the entire episode we were shown
just like
clips of like five minutes of it like
the same thing as like the trailer right
yeah
and you know i was honestly the opening
director
right now it was fun hype it's max yeah
the death note second opening yeah yeah
yeah
so it was [ __ ] hype yeah exactly and
i honestly went into it with high hopes
because why wouldn't i and
uh having because i watched the final
product as well and
i yeah i mean i would say i am
disappointed with
how it was adapted because it's i i feel
like the fights
deserved better treatments and i don't
know what happened in the production
process or
what kind of went on behind the scenes
but
it wasn't the final product that i was
personally hoping for yeah
i think it was fine like i saw a lot of
youtube videos where people were like
it's [ __ ] awful don't support this
[ __ ] it's terrible i was like you know
what like
it's still better than a lot of
adaptations we've had
like in recent memory you know like i
feel like they bastardized one punch man
season two way more
than this really i don't think so i mean
some of the one punch man fights were so
appalling in season two yeah but i feel
like huh i don't know it's it's a tough
one it's like
because for both of them i would
recommend the manga over the anime
yeah even then reading records of
ragnarok going back i'm like yeah this
is cool
and you could do this anime adaptation
the way that i think people wanted
but it's it's just never going to happen
like no i don't think we're ever going
to get the record of ragnarok adaptation
people want it
like no i don't think the story is that
good where a company would believe in it
enough
like i i read that i read it right and
it's cool yeah
but like the story's fine there isn't
much of a story like it's literally just
a battle show yeah like which is fine
it's cool but
i i was sitting there and i'm like i
could see why uh you know this is never
going to be the most popular market like
this is never going to be in like the
top 10.
you know what i mean it purely just
builds itself am i wrong
it doesn't need to be in the top 10 to
get a decent adaptation i mean you know
we can talk about the berserk adaptation
that's definitely a top ten marker
look at look at the adaptations it got
right i'm
so used to the current climate of
adaptation we've been getting and i'm
like
i just couldn't see an at like a show
that is literally all fighting
like 24 minutes yeah been done justice
where anime is right now
well i i would say look at god of high
school right going to high school has a
very mid-story
the story of the anime was very mid as
well um
but my [ __ ] god the fight scenes and
the animation were absolutely amazing
right
and i feel like god of high school and
records of ragnarok have a lot of
similarities and i mean they're both
just like tournament arc
the anime but the god of high school had
a big focus on martial arts
and like that kind of movement and i
feel like that that was specific to that
director
who knew very much i mean the director
was very [ __ ] talented yeah because
it's the same guy did you do
some but i mean i i mean i'm saying this
that you know
it could have got a good adaptation but
unfortunately i don't i think it's the
most five out of ten out of adaptation
right yeah it's pretty much bog standard
i thought like
it's a like at times it was
disappointing but when i read the manga
i was like well it kind of gives you the
same feeling
i'm not gonna lie really genuinely i
thought the
like the manga art was [ __ ]
incredible which is but which is really
which is why like you've already sold me
on this yeah it was it's a mediocre
story because it's just a [ __ ]
tournament arc but it's just
just dumb fun it's cool it's like a lot
it's just a lot of fun
it's just like hype thrown through i
know i'm gonna get [ __ ] for this i read
both their so there's a fight between uh
adam
of adam and eve and zeus and everyone
was like this is the most epic fight of
all time and i was like yeah it's pretty
good
and i i just i was reading it and i was
like i actually think it was better in
the anime even though it wasn't even
that good
are you are you for real yeah you
actually for real that
[ __ ] screenshot like [ __ ] you know
where the panel loads
like it's literally like reading the
manga
[Music]
it's literally reading the manga with
with with a pre-animated slide
welcome to trash days everybody what is
this take i'm hearing right now
i just think you were the guy who
couldn't get over the [ __ ]
like animated manga in uh like what was
it way of the house husband
and here you are in an actual anime that
needs animation because it's an action
anime
and you prefer it i realize this is
making me look terrible
i remember because that just the way it
was there was some animation that was
like i don't like how this looks but i
i this one they literally showed
screenshots of the [ __ ] fight in the
manga
you know what at least they just gave up
at least
at least they were like you know what
that's not even [ __ ]
i genuinely i wish i wish i was joking
because i know this is weird
but i genuinely didn't care i was like
that's fine wait so you prefer the anime
adaptation of
that okay so i watched the anime and
then i read the manga it might have been
an order thing but yeah
i was like yeah i think i just preferred
watching the uh
i really liked it i really liked the
music and the voice section it added so
much to it too
i've i've never i've never [ __ ] heard
that an opinion that's just
so wrong i i don't like i'm gonna get
grilled for this i know i want to know
if there's a single [ __ ] person
watching this right now that will
actually agree with he's like yeah
yeah finally finally i'm not the only
one just like i know that like
when you look at it you're like this
looks better but i don't know personal
preference i just thought that when i
was watching it i was like i think this
deserves
to be like have like music
a voice acting i don't know why i just
enjoyed that more like i was
when i carried on reading the manga i
thought this is good but like i actually
wanted to just
see the animation this is the guy who
watches seven deadly sins these season
three and she's like no
you know what it's probably better than
the one that's what i'm saying right
would i rather
what we get is just like the manga
colored
or would i rather seven deadly since
season three [ __ ] no get that out of
here they literally made the art ten
times worse than it is in the manga at
least they just took the [ __ ] art
from the manga
so like if i literally grabbed the manga
and colored it in and then played some
music as you read it and voice acting
yeah if
you if you literally can't animate it
don't just do that like you know what i
mean like just do the old cell
like movement well it's like it's like
[ __ ]
uh what is it like i love the like
circle tunes animation on youtube right
here
just [ __ ] do that bro